so um here uh we will start with as I
was telling you that we will start with
very Basics like protein structures are
very important because uh they interact
and they communicate and there is chance
that there is there are targets so uh
protein protein interactions to how the
how to do molecular visualization and
the molecular visualization is very
important of for cheminformatics or for
drug Discovery so all of you who would
be joining the program uh will be
learning about different molecular
visualization tools and how to utilize
them
then we will go into chem informatics
first we learn about the macromolecules
and then we learn about the small
molecules and uh how to explore the
chemical space like databases uh prepare
for virtual screening large databases
how to utilize them for drug Target
identification or for searching similar
ligands those are the key things and
then key businesses so there is always a
business component or industry component
associated with our training here so
then the focus is to go into those
databases explore those databases learn
about accessing those databases and
curate bioactive molecules and find the
right kind of molecules so that could be
specific for example kinase Inhibitors
or you're looking at very specific type
of Inhibitors with a specific type of
biochemical or physiochemical properties
so in this we will be again the Hands-On
part is there where we will be learning
about the softwares tools which are
freely available for you to utilize and
use them along with the mentor or after
the mentor session and practice on your
own because we will be also providing
the recorded session and the content and
the material and the links in a
systematic manner so that you learn from
the basic and even if you miss some of
the sessions you can go back and you'll
have it all with you to learn and do it
anytime you wish to but to it's
advisable to go along with the sessions
so that the desired outcome can be you
can get the desired outcome within that
time space
now uh exploring the protein Data Bank
um the protein Data Bank is a is is uh I
think is the cradle for structural
biology and for drug Discovery
structure-based drug Discovery so here
you we find all the experimental
structures and uh you can see that as
many as 60 000 structures are available
for humans and uh the uh the the list
goes on so we have a lot of structures
now compared to the previously and you
can see the number of structures that
are deposited and how they have grown
over the time and uh different like for
example SARS go to just in a few years
like three years there are more than uh
almost 3000 structures which is massive
in in understanding about a virus as
small as Sasuke 2 and having so much
structural information so just imagine
uh if you can understand the system
biology from that how many opportunities
are there to help so uh yeah I mean this
is the repository where we will be
finding the structures and understanding
the very basics of structure wow how to
understand the structure how to and
change something in there how to
incorporate mutations how to understand
the role of the mutations
and exploring different types of
research projects and structures so here
the participants will be joining they'll
be they they'll they'll have the
opportunity to explore the
three-dimensional space and find their
own structure of Interest disease of
interest and work with that structure to
further investigate and find out how
they are folding how they are maybe
functioning what are the key residues
where to find the active site what are
the solvent accessibility areas if there
is an allostatic site or a conventional
drug Discovery will work what are the
different types of drug Discovery
approaches one could take whether it is
a flex or whether it is uh what kind of
docking are we going to talk about what
kind of simulation so all those things
are possible
so we will elaborate on each of these
sessions for example Target structure
prediction I have already discussed a
lot about it so let's now so we'll not
discuss it further but these are will be
discussed in the context of a case study
so where we will be covering uh these
different topics and then we will be
working in that demonstration section in
the uh session during the session so
different types of modeling what are the
different uh techno technologies that
are used for the different tools that
are used for the pros and cons of using
one before another and what are the most
popular and validated methods that are
out there
um then Target identification and
virtual screening so virtual screening
is again very important in that drug
Discovery aspect because it's uh it's
being used so prashanjit has a question
which software do I need to install on
my Mac so for molecular visualization
prosenjit you can download Chimera or
buy Mall uh Chimera is free and very
powerful tool pymol is propriety but
also for academic there are free
versions which are available so I I
think you can start from there and have
a molecular visualization tool for sure
installed in your software in your
MacBook to start with so now about
virtual screening as I was telling you
that virtual screening so let's simplify
this so virtual screening aim aims to
computationally search the universe of
potentially organic molecules to
identify a manageable number of virtual
hits right so what it is doing is that
it is searching for molecule molecules
which could be considered as hits so
identifying them in the context of you
know how the initial screening could be
done so one such computational method
which we use for virtual screening is
docking like molecular docking so it is
used uh it uses the three-dimensional
structure of the target protein and
places small molecules Into The Binding
site so that is however a
computationally complex City a
computational complexity which is there
in docking
the evalu the evaluation of each small
molecules require consideration of its
low energy three-dimensional
conformation so this is what I was
telling you about before that uh when we
are doing uh virtual screening when we
are starting from virtual screening
there are different steps so one is
virtual screening another is then
intensive uh docking which is where it
is Computing all the different
parameters which are also important
which is not done at the screening stage
because screening you have a large large
Library
so generating low conformational three
day three-dimensional uh calculating the
energy of that conformation is not
possible at that point of time so uh we
have tools which do that uh and help us
screen from larger library to smaller
libraries but obviously what is the best
approach in bioinformatics for me is to
utilize multiple tools and then uh come
up with a table which has uh the top uh
top scorers from each of those tools so
that in a way in within bioinformatics
validates are work
so that will be covered in the fifth
session and then we'll learn about the
different uh steps and we have some
projects that we have already worked on
for example this is a drug Discovery
project that uh company has worked on
with Rosewell Park Cancer Institute
which we will be using as a case study
and then we have the actual session on
the other aspect after virtual screening
the in-depth screen docking and stages
of drug Discovery process so we will
learn about the pharmacological aspect
and Drug Discovery aspect and the
different confirmation uh using the top
softwares which are freely available but
also the concepts are like the logic is
same the software might vary but once
you know the logic once you know how to
utilize it what are the different
aspects I think the language Remains the
Same so it's important to understand the
basics and also the parameters that you
have to look into when you're looking
into these uh different aspects so one
of such experiments if you do with us
you will be able to explore on your own
and also we'll be able to help you in
case you use different softwares of your
own interest
so uh uh we in till the sixth session as
you could see we are learning about the
basics and we are learning from a very
beginner aspect to those to to for those
who are learning for the first time or
who want to learn from the very
beginning and basic level to that once
level I think first to say first to six
sessions are to help them uh reach at
that stage and then we go into more
advanced topics such as data science and
AI in healthcare chem informatics using
R uh these such these such topics so in
in this aspect I would like to talk a
little bit about qsir so qsr or qspr
these are uh based on uh the idea that
the structure of a molecule might
influence its physical chemical and
biological Behavior so we have been
using by the way qsr for last 40 years
in the practice of Agro chemistry
pharmaceutical chemistry toxicology and
many other assets of chemistry so qsr
has effectively modeled many
physiochemical properties such as
toxicity metabolism interaction between
drugs carcinogenesis so initial qsr
models such as hanche and Free Wilson
analysis very popular I guess
uses uh that use regression models to
relate potency and structural and
chemical properties such as chelation
substitution patterns surface activity
hydrophobicity Solutions sorry
solubility
electronic forces electrostatic forces
so
so in the context of the overall
protocol for constructing qsr model for
drug designing has been systematized and
many open source tools and softwares are
available uh for uh such steps to con
which are con which consists of several
modular steps for chemoinformatics and
machine learning techniques so in qsrs
in qsr modeling you start with molecular
encoding in which uh in which the
chemical structure of the drug molecule
is used to derive the chemical features
and the property and then you go on and
work on that so uh there is an
opportunity for those who want to learn
about this in the advanced modules that
we have prepared followed by the case
study so we have a case study which is
the discovery of c0t nip kinase
inhibitor for lung cancer and also
there's a blockbuster drug that recently
got
um
uh there's a company uh that was
recently got acquired by BMS uh BMS is a
Bristol miles uh it's a very big Pharma
company for 4.1 billion dollars
so and it's a it's a inhibitor it's a
kinase inhibitor and uh it works uh uh
it works on different uh uh
chemotherapies
um treatment so I think I mean that's
that's some of those case studies are
really helpful for understanding that uh
what are the success stories and uh also
uh what are the different ways these uh
companies I have utilized
um to reach at that stage
so I mean tools and softwares uh here's
a list from autodog to molecular docking
to Aven issue modeling so we will be
able to utilize uh many of these for the
understanding unless there are propriety
which is like Desmond Schrodinger or
Charm so other than that the ones that
are available we will be able to use for
the project work if you have a
hypothesis if you have a structure that
you have started working with or if you
have a disease type that you are working
on so those who are would be joining so
we have different modes of joining the
program so
um one could choose to join between for
one month or three months so for three
months we will be able to work on
Research proposals and then we also have
the research fellowship program which
actually helps students to complete a
research project so
um then as I was telling you that this
entire Discovery is focused drug
Discovery is focused on the modern
approach so you can work on oncology
related projects you can work on
infectious disease related projects and
you can use multiple types of data types
to be able to come to the drug Discovery
or drug Target or you can use several
other approaches that we can work with
so it's up to you and it's also you will
be also learning about these approaches
if you have not uh if you think that
you're new to all of this and you're not
ready for it so that's why the beginner
level is there so that you are ready for
all of this so again here the focus is
AI in molecular drug Discovery we
discussed about artificial intelligence
playing a role and also deep learning
has a huge role so we will discuss all
those aspects in this session and then
understanding that from the point of
view of how these different Technologies
so Google has Deep Mind program has the
open AI program with uh
so incorporating the new technologies
that real like really impactful
technologies that are came into 2023
2022 so I don't think there are any
other programs which utilizes that but
this is what we've been doing we are
updating it like every month every week
and so that we can enable uh those who
are joining to get to the latest
Technologies learn about the latest
advancements and apply them into their
research so uh this will include like
understanding and this would include
like Pharma and bioinformatics Industry
uh integration this will include like
different types of softwares for
molecular visualization this will
include Advanced chem informatics which
is to further manipulate the structures
this will include the research projects
that I've been discussing about and this
will include Integra education of omics
data in the search projects if that is
what your direction is it will include
you to work on Pharma projects which is
for specific Pharma problems it will
include uh for you to work on different
infectious disease projects that are
there for example SAS Cove 2 and
learning about different uh binding
properties we have already published
articles on malaria vaccine design and
resistance using popular population
genetics and Drug Discovery and
molecular Dynamics on all of that so in
the end we have a case study which is on
successful as well as the frailed drug
development to give you an insight about
how what worked and what has not worked
this is a recent publication that we
were able to complete
through this training and it's an
infectious disease genomics research
which was recently published in
molecules so I think that concludes my
presentation education for today and we
have still the registration and the cost
and the scholarships and really exciting
time because we have a really great
scholarship model which is just
available for next for few days which is
I think what Spurs will be talking about